So I mentioned earlier, it's this kind of thing that can really make
you want to tear your hair out. As you can see, I've been in
lots of these situations. Okay, so we're facing a challenging situation, in that
we've got to do some scraping from a site that's really making us work
for it. Let's talk about a best practice for screen scraping. So the
first thing we want to do here is as I mentioned is, look
at how the browser itself makes requests. And with the developer tools, we
have quite a few ways in which we can do that. We can also
look at the wire traffic if we really needed to
using something like wire sharp. Then we want to emulate that
in our code. Now if everything blows up, we're going to
need to take a look at our HTTP traffic in some
way. And then just return to one and work through
this again until we get it right. If we follow this
process, we have a pretty effective strategy, for dealing with any
problems we have making requests from sites we'd like to scrape.